dc analysis now mr speaker
during july and august we didn't have
the means to accurately assess risks
within countries
and within regions the kind of
comprehensive
office for national statistics data that
we now have through their testing
was never available overseas and it was
too easy for the virus to migrate
between regions
without borders or boundaries however
as jbc resources have strengthened we've
been able to collaborate much more
closely with other governments
and their health authorities this has
led
to a more forensic picture now
for the first time we're able to
consider a granular approach to
assessing
detailed data abroad and i've looked at
whether this means we can implement
regionalized systems
for international travel corridors
but in many cases the international data
is still
simply too patchy and in all cases
there is next nothing to prevent people
from moving around
within a country's border i know that
people will rightly point out
that infection rates also vary across
the united kingdom and indeed they do
but the difference is
that the countries we're talking about
all by definition
have higher rates of infection than we
do ourselves
so i hope the house understands that the
jbc and this government are therefore at
present
unable to introduce regional travel
corridors from within
the geographical boundaries of a nation
state
however however when a region has
natural boundaries
like an island for example the risk
diminishes significantly
and that presents us with a real
opportunity
our passenger locator form combined with
nhs test and trace
will give us a clear picture and has
started to give us a clear picture of
exactly where
infections are coming from and as a
result i can today announce a new
island's policy for the first time we
have the data and the capacity
to add and remove specific islands from
quarantine
which providing while still providing
maximum protection
to the uk public there are thousands of
islands across the globe far too many
for jbc to monitor
uh on a detailed level but in their
sisterhouse if i outline the four
guiding principles which we intend to
apply
first this regionalized approach can
only apply to land that has clear
boundaries or border in other words
an island second the data collected must
be robust reliable
and internationally comparable third
the island must have direct flights from
the uk or the very minimum
transport must have take must be able to
take place through
quarantine exempt territories and fourth
the fcdo travel advice should align as
far as practicable
the jbc methodology that i've just
described for islands has been developed
in
consultation with the chief medical
officer and public health
england this new capability means that
we'll now be able to
nuance our decisions first and foremost
to safeguard the health
of british citizens but also to enable
british tourists to enjoy trips to
islands
even if the mainland is deemed too risky
however it is worth noting that the
policy will not necessarily open up
additional islands immediately for
example
when we remove spain from the travel
corridor list there were
24 cases per 100 000 today there are 127
cases and it remains too high in the
belerick and canary islands as well
on the other hand greece remains within
our travel corridor program
but our new analysis shows that some of
the islands are well
outside of the parameters indeed despite
overall greek infection levels being
lower than ours
scotland has already felt compelled
to add the entirety of greece including
the mainland
to the quarantine however using our
newly acquired jbc
data we're now in a position to remove
greek islands
where holiday makers are at risk of
spreading the new
infection back home and seven greek
islands will therefore be removed from
travel list at 4 am on wednesday
the 9th of september whilst maintaining
mainland greece mr speaker i want to
thank our medical experts who forged
these professional relationships
improved capacity
however i want to make one thing clear
during coronavirus
traveling during coronavirus is not
without
risk so please if you're traveling
go with your eyes open and remember
breach and quarantine
is not only an offence which can gain
you a criminal record
but you are also putting the lives of
your loved ones at risk
and loved ones of those you've never met
before at risk
2.